To add a dependency to a Gradle project,
we first need to declare the repository
to fetch the dependency from.
The most basic sort of repository
is just a folder full of jars,
which Gradle calls a flat
directory repository.
All repository configuration is done
inside a repositories script block.
For a flat directory repository,
we just add a flat dir block and
configure the directories
we want to include.
This is great option if you're migrating
an existing project to Gradle, or
using a dependency if it's not
available from a remote repository.
But it also means you forego
a lot of Gradle's advanced
dependency management features.
The repository script block also
allows you to use shortcut methods for
commonly used repositories such as
mavenCentral, mavenLocal, or jcenter.
Simply call the appropriate method, and
the repository will be
automatically added.
This is by far the most common
way to declare a repository.
Gradle also supports resolving
managed dependencies from Maven and
and IV repositories.
The syntax for both is the same.
Simply place your configuration
in Ivy or Maven block.
For both Ivy and Maven repositories,
the only required configuration element
is the location of the repository,
expressed as a URL.
In some cases, credentials may be
required to access a repository.
You can easily provide a username and
password by placing them
inside a credentials block.
Gradle supports a number of protocols
for accessing repositories.
In addition to the standard http and
https,
Gradle also supports sftp and
file-based repositories like this.